should we be fired about face darling
please leave room other doors apart so
there please hold photo but also has the
stairs I went of children anyone who's
on they have to use the stairs would
they please and there are others to exit
the room before they go so i'll be the
last ones moving them from the hope you
very well on our 75 will be in the
public car parked at the side of the
civic sweet please do not delay or a bad
way to deflect any billions please do
not return the building until give me
permission to do so I felt sore staff
and please note that this meeting will
be deposited apologies for absence I got
canceled black council book Clayton
councillor Marek anybody else non
members attending good evening loving of
crystalline from the boring parts of
teddy
you want to sit at the back there Dalton
collector minutes of meeting held on
17th of June yep please any declarations
of interest any questions will notice
motions like marriages rather then go to
Adam seven hold thank you Barry's going
to talk us through these are what an
agenda this evening though and just want
to say before we start to cut off thanks
to the finance team and to internal it
for the support and this is we can't
join the years over thank you very much
for everything it's been easy on this
last year has it it's been crazy stuff
we're losing you as well I said yes I
mean would we are coming in to delete
account of end of almost 17 years of
being appointed to the example I've been
here forever on an offer below that time
actually but tell yes it's it's sad but
we're not quite there yet so the rest of
the zoo and the the hasn't been of its
claim to work our way through but yes
it's is coming towards the end almost
almost I have a very caring very
generally asking questions as we go over
here well can we go through each page as
it comes certainly yes yeah yeah there's
a page-turning exercise yet no problem
and so just starting on page one which
is provides a note to do with the
outcome about work I'll just take the
the committee through each of the points
on page one then so starting with
independence and where we required it's
your external auditors to identify any
potential threats to our independence
as part of our planning processes we
haven't identified any this year in
terms of the status of the financial
statements audit and I'll see this
report was was drafted as at the
seventeenth of September and so it knows
there that we have substantially
completed and work on the following page
i'll just take members through the
position on the items that the flag
that's outstanding and as it says there
we've obtained sufficient appropriate
audit evidence for the significant
issues and risks identified in our audit
plan and our audit materiality was set
at seven hundred thousand pounds and
we're required to report all what we
described is non-trivial adjustments
greater than sorry non-trivial
unadjusted all the difference is greater
than 25,000 pounds and again one of the
appendices pendix it's to the report
highlights those during the course of
the audit says they're there was one
material misstatement that was
identified by relating to the incorrect
classification of an investment amount
as cash and that has actually been
corrected in the financial statements as
a result of foreign eliza ng our work
there were some other classification
errors in relation to the allocation of
debtors and creditors between long-term
and short-term on the balance sheet and
they've also been corrected they were
classification errors only so there was
no bottom line impact on the council's
financial position as a result of those
adjustments
and there's one in year unadjusted all
get difference which is showing that
appendix to this is in relation to the
treatment of some grants and again this
is only a classification error so there
is no impact on the bottom line so this
is their subject to satisfactory
completion of our outstanding work we
anticipate issuing an unqualified to
true and fair opinion on financial
statements for the year just moving
through the rest of those points and the
control environment we didn't identify
any significant deficiencies in internal
control and governance reporting getting
subject to completion of our outstanding
work on the an governance statement
which is now done the contents of that
are not being consistent or misleading
in terms of our understanding of the
council the whole of government accounts
and the council is actually below the
threshold for the full assurance review
that's required on that so all we
require to do is the external auditors
is just submit what's called an
assurance statement which effectively
confirms that the council is below the
threshold required to do that by second
of October and I don't envisage of any
problems with that and then finally on
there the use of resources again we we
are satisfied in all significant
respects at the council's put in place
proper arrangements to secure economy
efficiency and effectiveness in its use
of resources and however as it says
there and it's details later on in the
report we did identify some weaknesses
in relation to monitoring of certain
contracts and as we work through the
report we can cover that more detail
later
page 2 just provides the position view
it as a sales activate this report was
drafted and just on the Left fairly with
its status so clearance of outstanding
issues then there's three points they're
all of which we have now covered and
have reached a satisfactory conclusion
we have raised and some we had some
findings that are reported here in
relation to grant income and again there
are more details on that later on report
and but in terms of the other two we're
satisfied with the position we're at so
in terms of what's still outstanding and
we have our own internal review process
so that will be ongoing until the day
that we sign off and receive the final
draft statement accounts for agreed
amendments obviously that will happen
after this meeting we require to do
what's called a subsequent events review
where we just make sure that nothing
significant has happened between the day
of the balance sheet and the day that
our orbit opinion is signed so again
that's something that we will finalize
before signing off again we're not aware
of anything at this stage that cause any
problems there then technical clearance
and has actually now happened since this
report was drafted and then finally the
the management representation letter
which again will be there with at the
end of this meeting so we expect to be
able to the shower issue a little bit
opinion by the deadline for 35 certain
before we go any further I apologize at
least I didn't
this is Denise may be about to introduce
yourself time today story on the news
section 151 officer much for district
council and commence the engagement on
neutral basis until this is until the
position is ratified and full council
and commenced my engagement to personal
to three weeks ago so they just possible
selves I said tell it to be sorry that's
a great and any questions on 253 and so
this just provides a bit more detail on
the independence considerations that
we're required to have as well as well
as details of our fees and as I said
earlier we hadn't identified any issues
with regards to independence and the
fees there are as reported in our audit
plan it's just worth noting there that
in terms of the housing benefits work
that we do annually that work is still
ongoing so the fever bought it there is
is the scale fee that was prescribed by
the Audit Commission as they were public
sector all the appointments as they now
are
so Paige fine just documents our
significant audit risk areas and so when
we presented our audit plan at the
previous committee we identified two
significant risks and management
override of controls and revenue
recognition both of which are shown
there on page five in terms of both of
those we've obviously performed out from
the work that we intended to to satisfy
ourselves at there were no issues
arising out of that and pleased to
report we've got nothing there to bring
to your attention and as part of our
planning process once we've received the
draft financial statements we do it
effectively do another risk assessment
because then we've got numbers in front
of us that we can actually actually look
at and as a result of that we identified
to further and significant risks
relating to the valuation of land and
buildings and to the pension liability
both of these involve quite a
significant level of estimation that's
the nature of valuations and of getting
to a point where the pension liability
is valued and in terms of the valuation
of land and buildings the movement that
we we saw in the cat accounts was not in
line with our expectations and when I
say that I mean we we form a broad view
based on what we think the movement
would be in terms of our awareness of
movements in general indices and so on
and so that coupled with the high
estimation level involved there resulted
in us highlighting that as a significant
risk and we've undertaken appropriate
work to address that risk and we've not
identified any issues there so we're
comfortable that the the valuation of
the council's assets is appropriate and
we've considered the the value of the
independence of the value and their
competence and we don't have any
concerns over that and in terms of the
pension liability again that is a very
complex number obviously the council
engages a naturally professional actuary
to to help arrive at that number and to
assess and the estimate involved there
and again we've looked at the figures in
the account we're happy they're
consistent with what the actual is
reported we have no concerns over the
competence of the actor either so again
no issues identified in relation to that
of a significant return your sermon it
in in the past few months a six months
that the position of the reserves or the
revenue available to the council seems
to have reduced substantially is is
there a High Line being a few few months
ago everything booked on fedora and
suddenly we seem to be in a situation
where the money available to the council
has suddenly become very limited is
there any insight into why this should
be your that's that's nothing to do we
notice that that's the more the future
money I I agree that is there any
figures are the figures that the
auditors have been working or not it
correctly I was going to just tear each
other's good clarify when he meant yeah
we're moment or whether it's something
soon sort of money available to two
councils going forward yeah and if it's
the lasso then of course it's not
something we can order because we
haven't going there so it's not one else
currently accounts or what we would
cover but that's an issue is probably
and use resources which we have got they
sure in the document when we're looking
at right the clerk a sort of future
financial planning so maybe we can cover
them when we get to the possession yeah
it's not past no no I yeah they say big
you know I was concerned of we were
working from the wrong basis if you you
know what make me a story where you at
us it's in the DS in the venture yeah we
know no I got you forward yeah no I ok
chairman couldn't because you've got
some conclusions sorry no next function
sorry those those ones you were happy
with sorry is the next page sorry
general yeah and so this yeah yeah no
it's the next page on question yeah ok
so this section of the report just talks
about a significant accounting estimates
and management judgments so in terms of
valuation of property I've just been
talking about that and that just
provides a little bit more information
there of what's involved with that
estimate and as I've already said that
conclusion against evaluation of land
property was satisfied with the
independence of the valuer that he's
been objective and that was competent on
to take his work again the estimated
pension liability I've discovered when
talking about the significant risks at
mokona just provides a little bit more
information there just confirmed in the
conclusion column that we are satisfied
with the position reflected in the
council's accounts finally on that pays
bridget provision for bad and doubtful
debts the council had a number of
different categories of debtor depending
on the particular revenue stream and
again there's a level of estimation
involved there in terms of deciding to
what extent it might not be possible to
recover some of that debt and again
we've looked at each of those revenue
streams we've looked at how the
council's calculated that provision and
we're comfortable that it's been done
and
really what 12 pitch to my dish ah the 7
12 and two more waves yeah academy
that's why I wondered where Michael
hello and I fall asleep for these four
pages would you like us to stick to the
page and bring in it doesn't matter now
Joshua jihad we just I'm band evident
now so that's okay sorry yeah until 12
yeah it was the people and okay so this
section of the report just to highlight
some issues that we we've identified
during the audit that we wanted to bring
to the attention of the committee so the
first point now is regarding the
preparation of the financial statement
presented hold it when when the accounts
were presented officers noted that they
had identified it over to miss
statements and all that management were
aware of those issues I have noted there
and the presence in the draw financial
statements those areas was potentially
indicative of some process issues in
some capacity issues during the the
production process of preparing the
draft account and we will come on to
that and a little bit more detail later
on on page page 10 actually apologies
that's a typo day page tentative
reporters numbered by us in terms of the
areas that were pointed out they have
been corrected so we're comfortable that
the position
in the accounts in relation to those is
correct this was something like all
doubt that you say you've raised
recommendations regarding both those
matters now yes yeah I'll talk a little
bit its intentions yes okay that was the
same thing German okay 13 okay it's so
both of these points relate to grants so
the first one in relation to the
treatment of bronze now the the code
code local practice which governs how
local government accounts are prepared
it's very specific about the way grants
should be treated and well that's if you
want to bore the committee here with the
in-depth details but there's there's
guidance around conditions on grand so
if the grant awarded body has stated
that the council must do something with
that money and if they don't then it has
to be given back then it needs to be
treated in a particular way in the
statements if those conditions aren't
present and it's treated in a slightly
different way so this this particular
point here related to the treatment of
grants in that respect and so there was
an icing that was incorrectly recognized
in income when it should actually have
been taken to the balance sheet as a
deferred grant so that money could be
released in later years when the
expenditure was incurred because there
were conditions attached to that grant
that were only going to be fulfilled and
in 1516 so the following financial year
and repairs
but that was an that particular amount
related to a smaller trivial item but
further investigation then highlighted
the hundred of 40,000 that's reflected
in the unadjusted misstatement shedule
so the grant that was treated
incorrectly was around 10,000 pounds in
his relation to a festival that the
council agreed to put on we looked and
satisfied ourselves that there were no
other issues that would push the value
of those items that were incorrectly
treated up above our trivial level I eat
higher than 25,000 pounds so then the
the second issue in relation to grants
was regarding the classification of them
so again the code specifies particular
ways of treating them if there are no
conditions attached then instead of
taking them directly to one of these
service headings in the comprehensive
income and expenditure account it should
be taken to the nonspecific grant income
line a bit further down again I don't
want to pull the committee with the
details of that that is purely a
classification issue so this hundred and
forty thousand pounds the fact it's not
being adjusted doesn't affect the
council's bottom line it just means it's
sitting in the wrong place in the
comprehensive income and expenditure
account thank you i would just like to
ask that by cause of this myth
specification could it have been
possible for the council as their monies
that it wasn't entitled to do so and did
you ascertain that we hadn't and we
didn't identify any expenditure that was
inappropriate this this particular test
was looking at the income side if you
like so it was looking at how the income
the ground income and
limited in the accounts but there was
nothing that came out of that that
suggested and that any money had been
spent inappropriately or ahead of time
if you like or anything like that and
then come demanded Barry was referring
to the 10,000 it actually ended up in
our reserve account rather than actually
spending if you didn't spend that money
incorrectly create anything put it in
the reserve for classification basically
but it yeah which meant it okay page for
change and so this section of the report
relates to governance matters and
quality of reporting so the the first
item there and the financial statement
preparation just provides some further
details on the the point I lead it to
earlier and regarding the production
process for the accounts and so we we've
given a draft set of statements for
audit on the seventh of July and that
set of statements wasn't what we need to
be complete in terms of there was
something complete notice there's some
times that were still in a very draft
format so I they weren't really
auditable because we knew they were in
the final position effectively as far as
officers were concerned and it's also
worth noting that the deadline for
providing a draft sever counts to the
auditors is the 30th of June and that
deadline was missed we've been provided
with it seven days late and now in terms
of property with reporting this to you
there's no direct impact of that on our
opinion and however going forward over
the next two to three years the the
deadlines for submitting accounts like
to the auditors and getting them signed
off ie the auditors issue in therapy you
know I got to come forward quite
significantly so instead of signing off
at the end of sep tember
in the next three years you'll be
signing off at the end of july so
because these issues potentially
indicative of capacity and process
issues and being able to get things done
within the required timeframe and we
felt it was important to to highlight
those and we have raised a
recommendation regarding that and for
the council to how are we the universe
but all that no because the key
reporting deadline is the 30th at
September that's the date at which the
accounts have to be the audited accounts
have to be published the legislation
just say that the the draft accounts
need to be authorized for issue
presented to the auditors by the 30th of
G but there is no penalty for that
there's no financial penalty all yeah I
just want a grandfathered a little bit
on the video that you wanna be signed a
balance sheet and send it over to you
but not for statements oh yeah yes are
we gonna and written on so they already
that was supposed to happen on the
twenty-seventh of july so i'm saying is
yes according technically median
submitted on time but we didn't really
impaired you know so there's been like
that's a valid point there's been no
impact this year on our delivery of the
orbit so i said earlier on we expected
able to issue an opinion because of the
way out our fieldwork was timed we
weren't due to start until the end of
july and there's a yes yeah that's about
the other thing is we didn't actually do
any entries after signing the balance
sheet only after the audit the two of
two items that we have already
identified and beginner to you that that
has to be done other two adjustments we
did after the audit was completed
do me to be paid two months earlier yep
just jam did it did this have any impact
upon the field work where you had to
undertake and did it impact on the cost
for the council no as I say I'll have
field work for this year's program to
start on the twenty-seventh of july so
we had a draft set of accounts prior to
starting that and it's not held us up in
any way service as I said we will be
delivering our opinion by the deadline
yeah well I think probably my answer
that which also wouldn't put in place to
make sure that we don't be sitting there
the night if that I do come care and
recognize the points that have been made
by our external auditors it's actually
correct we didn't hear the deadline and
I think it was key in terms of the
recommendations and recommendations are
focusing on what is our action plan to
ensure that this doesn't happen in
future and that's where I want to focus
on in terms of application that we have
a project team that are now to start to
think about the processes that need to
be in place to ensure that actually then
all of the details can be complete long
time and that there's a readiness for
this acceleration and the most
authorities are actually starting to the
liquor this in advance of programmers
recognizing it is quite significant
leaked and what we've been accustomed to
and we chosen to put all of that in
place that I think the girls into I mean
person and didn't disagree with any of
what you've commented and we're going to
take action to make sure that we're in
that's a nice in future Thank You
general really pleased to hear that
that's what I expected to hear anyway
will this project team be reporting to
this committee or another committee or
just to a port forward polio well I'd
hope that we don't you come up with an
action plan that will bring yourself to
answer to review as well so that we can
clear what other processes but I think
what we need to clear on what where are
the potential bottlenecks growth
potential issues and part of many
systems and that need to be looked at
and then we'll come up with an action
plan that will bring back to this
meeting okay thank you just post add
that question was asked about whether as
a sort of penalty that applies to the
authority and the answer is no there
isn't however in the past so the only
commissioners running things if
authorities were late in having their
account signed off and you're not going
to be but but if they've been late in
that respect then there was something
and change the national report now as
the deadline comes further and further
forward there's going to be a lot more
scrutiny I mean you're not alone in
having a challenge of getting your
account source output but the point of
raising now is that you've got some time
to get things sorted out so you don't
end up being the councillors named and
change that's being lazy thank you
anything only 15 16
right then this is the use of resources
section of our report so page 16 just
and describes the the work that we've
done and what we look at and then the
following pages provide the victor
behind so this looks at the financial
resilience element of our use of
resources work the other one being
challenging economy efficiency and
effectiveness which which follows and so
we identified financial resilience as a
significant risk in our audit plan the
reason being the local government
generally is obviously facing quite
quite significant financial pressures at
the moment and has been for a number of
years and it doesn't look like they're
necessarily going to disappear in the
near future and probably less so since
May and so that was the reason behind
identifying it as a as a significant
risk in order to address that what we've
done is we've looked at the council's
medium term financial strategy and we've
considered the the assumptions that have
been applied in arriving at that medium
term financial strategy so this covers
the next five years and it's the one
that was presented to council and there
in the year and so it's part of looking
at that we've kind of we identified the
savings so that the council needs to
make 1.6 million pounds of savings over
the next five years and we've looked at
what the council's doing to to address
those now it is yet to directly identify
where those savings are going to come
from however that is in the context of
the fairly significant organisation of
change that the counter is currently
going through and I think the the key
thing is that we obviously aware the
senior level management restructure has
taken place and one of the the drivers
behind that was to achieve savings going
forward and so that demonstrates that
the council is aware of the challenges
it faces financially and it's taking
steps to
though is already and as things progress
in terms of the service reviews and so
on I expect those savings and the areas
where those savings come from will be
identified particularly I believe when
the new corporate plan and it's been
finalized because then the council will
have new high-level priorities and
objectives so the detail can then start
to be worked out in terms of the level
of reserves that the council has coming
back to the point and raised earlier and
as at the balance sheet date for this
set of accounts the reserves were about
800,000 pounds just over with a marked
reserves of around the 2 million pound
mark I believe so earmarked reserves are
fairly consistent with what they have
been in previous years and the council
expects them to stay at that level and
depending on whether or not there needs
to be any drawdown from them now at this
stage it's not clear whether that will
be necessary recognizing the risks that
the council faces in terms of the
general fund balance the medium term
financial strategy and that's
highlighted that that general fund
balance should be maintained at a level
of 1.2 million and that helps mitigate
against some of the risks so the council
expects to push up that that balance
over the net wealth next year and
maintain it over the life of the ntfs
yeah and so our conclusion there is that
we're satisfied the council has adequate
arrangements in place to make sure that
financial resilience is achieved however
that is obviously in the context of the
ongoing pressures but in terms of our
conclusion initiate we haven't
identified any issues on the financial
resilience side
they seemed I think actually but um
where the offices have got no issues for
2014-15 unless you pass specific
question to ask about house no I'm not
him yeah I read this carefully and I had
a resident contact me on this subject
show us her Eagles notice who letís look
at me and he drew to my president due to
my attention that he made the audit is
specifically aware of a short coming on
a particular contract monitoring
contract project management well I what
I haven't managed to understand is a
what that was and be how we knew then
I've got a kind of a third question that
says what framework is the council that
are put in place so that all of our
contracts are project managed in an
appropriate way I know you say we
haven't come to harm but to me it
alarmed me in alarm me because so much
of my professional
was was actually involved in ensuring
that this sort of project management
monitoring management was achieved on
contract canoe okay Phil would I explain
yes the potential referral was remember
public and it was after I think a
Freedom of Information and request for
some contract monitoring information
related to a particular project now the
project subsidy is practically small and
contained but the answer that they
definitely correctly true response was
that there were no documents relating to
the contrary merging at all so the
member public was sort of concerned that
indicated there was some sort of more
one concern that was the case and to you
can send there might be some sort of
wider issue so it's a valid question to
be asking and certainly an hour be there
really should have been some
documentation for that so the council
has been quite correct and responding so
it wasn't anything but the issue is that
they've children and this particular
situation there was nothing documented
and the officer in question had left the
council the time we was looking at it so
there was no retain knowledge of course
going on nobody actually has anything
gone wrong and that's I think that's
that's quite important here and also it
was a comparatively silicon contained
issue so we looked into that realize
there was an issue lieut to see whether
these a wider issue and the other
examples we looked at there was some
sort of short coming intensive the
documentation is available stepping back
what we're trying to look out from from
our user results is responsibilities and
that's really where it comes in is is
there is there a material issue of the
council well we've got some issues with
sort of smaller on trans there is sort
of guidance that officers should take
into consideration when procuring
and suggestions as to what the things
might want to be done some sort of
indicates there might be looked at a
frequency of meetings of things we
looked at to make certain the contracts
on on track but there's a variable level
of a practical implementation for the
bigger contracts different patron timing
so what we wrote to conclude is that yes
there were some issues yes something
could be done to make certain that
there's I'm also consistent
implementation even checking that things
are being being done a lot of a sort of
a a more senior officer looking at
something to make some other things
there or there's an internal that
reviewed cuttings in telling it to the
council to work out what's going to
what's going to work but basically we're
able to saying that nothing's basically
gone wrong there are things that can be
better but for the material the bigger
contracts you have got some sufficient
arrangements in place so there should be
some paperwork yeah I think I think the
issue that the one that was referred and
it is a particularly unfortunate
situation where the officer in question
hadn't documented early and had left so
there's just nothing there to say it
it's been monitored as I said looking at
it it doesn't look like there and he's
going wrong with it what'swhat's came
out of it slow looks like the sort of
thing you'd be with your commissioning
so we're not concerned about things
having gone whitewood but but that's
that's basically the history behind so
to the individual in question asked to
see some documentation about that
particular contract there was none and
then referred to us because they won't
happen because come back on that
chairman I mean I I'm many years ago
there was a contract working party
committee which actually I chaired
strangely well it wasn't that strange
what was one of the few big runner
counsel who was actually working
professionally in
field I kind of feel that there should
be a universal framework around all
contracts no matter what size 22 to be
fulfilled to ensure that projects are
are managed through their point from
inception to delivery and therefore into
maintenance obviously vary according to
the liver of risk and size of contract
and I would just probably ask trevor
through you with the knees expect that
to be part of the recommendation and the
project framework we'd expect to see now
so one of the things that have been
strengthened is the roles we now have a
director or assistant director has
responsibility for this area of work we
also have a new contract procedure note
that's being prepared and reviewed with
a number of us involved in actually the
draft and I've actually got first copy
draft as well to go through and quite
making sure or ensuring that we have a
lot of detail around or will be required
in terms of contract contract monitoring
and control management going forward and
like yourself again soon and that's
going to be from in sections for the
whole life cycle of the year which from
the project we also have a new
procurement strategy that's in the
process as well as being reshaped and
drafted so have been out
it's going to be a lot more focus on
this to a form to prevent contract
leakage some of the big areas
particularly public sector that we
historically aren't as good at and we
want to really focus on that to ensure
that we're getting value for money and
that we're delivering the outcomes that
we anticipated when we initially
commissioned the activity so again
there's a lot of work that's planned in
this area I'm going forward so is the
thing that more than happy to share that
once against a position where where
where where it's ready for for
consumption thank you please come in
winter in tennis too it's probably just
worth on appendix 2 so this is the audit
differences they've been identified and
the key key element of that is the
unadjusted all the differences in the
table there on page 23 so just to
quickly talk members through that
there's not that much on there there's
only two items to numerical items and
then there's to disclosure matters in
terms of the numerical items the 140,000
pounds will be familiar from our
discussions earlier on regarding the
classification of grant income and as I
said it at the time that is purely a
classification issue so there's no
impact on the surplus or deficit and the
the top one there in relation to the
impairment of the South Street depot is
it says just above that that is actually
a prior year miss statement so we are
required to bring those into this
schedule if they
have an impact on the current year so
it's related to an impairment of the
South Street depo that was identified
last year but wasn't actually booked the
last year instead it was booked this
year so that meant effectively last
year's expenditure was understated and
dishes expenditure is overstated so
while we report the potential impact of
that on the in year financial
performance I either service or deficit
on the provision of services that
fifty-four thousand pounds does not have
any impact on the year-end position as
is reflected in the table underneath
there's no impact on the general fund
balance and so I just I just wanted to
highlight that and take the members
through that
appendix it's not me anybody else ? life
is very good recommendation on someone
things that you mentioned yes everything
absolutely actions that were produced in
to address some of the weaknesses that
have been identified and it's like this
to the which then another area so the
dark presentation later
recommendations of the 20 resolves why
that the report noted that
implementation of any actual plans you
reported through the audit process the
brain proofread so that the chairman of
the audit committee and cyber statement
is our lives we must report great food
right so that goes right soon aight
statement yeah pretty shy yeah most of
the stuff induced financial statement is
already present in the subcommittee or
some earlier forum it just to go to it
the main highlights is actually on 1.3
which is shows our current position in
terms of general fund me earlier
predicted in one of the reports the
medium term financial strategy I think
the original one which is the februari
presentation we said that we will draw
down 233,000 but actually we managed to
draw down only 188,000 that is purely
because of the restructure the redesign
of the management structure we had a
excess of expenditure in the year that
has gone by which will deliver for about
750,000 pounds saving in the new year
right so that's the cause of that and
then we want 5.3 yeah showing our
performance in terms of surpluses and
deficits during the air yesterday when I
read this with me design of senior
middle management incurred a one of the
dozens thing 600 central tales of here
that was for one person who doesn't say
they told us he would be stroking yes I
thought some of them well it's drove it
centrally knee yeah that's right the
statement sila wagon we had some
additional income of 469 thousand
between in budgets that helped us to
meet some of the redundancy costs and we
had a salary savings of 336,000 which
was a call because we didn't fill the
vacancy straight away we prudently
manage the vacancies and as John said he
had 671 thousand pounds one off
redundancy costs for 12 thought staff
the fees planning fees pre-application
fees windmill licensing fees and
recycling disposal we had a surplus on
those ones we had a kind of we didn't
kind of meet the income targets of the
building control car parts and local
land charges
interesting conference actually want any
papers still just put in that fountain
which slopey said anything new yeah our
charge is going up yeah meet my best
people did buy a pound for a car parking
challenge yes very loud he's still out
doing that yes I mean he generate for a
million pounds worth of income garvanza
just put it into perspective the other
important issues to highlight is we had
a 1.3 million capital spend but we
managed to only spend nine on the
captain but that doesn't mean that we we
had stopped the spending of the 1.3
million acres are all the way to the
into the new year to continue on those
projects the reserve statement tells you
that we started 2.1 million ended up
with 1.7 million we have to draw down
nearly three hundred seventy four
thousand pounds just as one off which
will be paid back this year to to meet
the tri-annual valuation of pension
deficit to not allow the deficit to grow
so every three years we look at the
deficit figure and contribute the
employees contribution that was 1.9
million so we managed to meet most of it
and we only have to draw down 374 from
the reserve to pay in advance which we
will pay back this year I don't
understand you don't understand that
Jared Wright 11.9 million cause it's the
deficit that goes for that also
that's not the influence that's right in
pioneer square every three years we had
to chop up the pension fund to make sure
the deficit doesn't grow so in order to
meet that cost we have to find money
from somewhere so it will be over three
year period but we had to pay it in
advance to make some savings so the
savings is around about sixty to seventy
thousand pounds if you had paid it in
one lump so we decided to pay it as one
lump sum and in order to do that to meet
that cost we have to draw down some
reserve money to pay it in advance and
then we budgeted in the count here and
they combine if you pay back into a
reserve ah yeah okay right got it yes we
went to the shops we got something
imperfectly as we bought it now here I
am I understand that yeah yeah that
concludes the parcel statement so the
detail segment is there if you have any
specific questions i love to answer
those ones
Kevin just their room just just to
remind me I suppose this these financial
statements will vary for council is that
they also know how you're in committee
approves it chandigarh to commit their
pros and cons if they know that sorry
one everything you ask if you are happy
with the financial statements you will
be signing it all right so we yeah and
the article me did right so as if I
asked questions him so the only
counselors who eventually we will
actually approve yeah this financial
stone are those are very a present
absolutely yep have you though so now
you have something another pressure
thing well exactly don't imagine i'm
glad you interjecting presenters you
that extra sense of shame and actually
what it does do it makes me think well
in terms of my due diligence what should
I be doing there well god I question
that I can see that you do legally yes
the coverage is worthwhile mentioning
that Saturday's the full statement in
its entirety has been subject to audit
by the
auditors and that's really in some ways
to give us insurance of their
appropriate nurse from their accuracy
such as well defined in storm that with
you is the ones of you just discussed in
earlier report I'm glad you said that
because that was where where I was
relying I was relying above and all of
these disclosures and discussions
leading to this to which most of us
already knew most of the figures in
there from various empty event reports
the council so it shouldn't be any
surprise to anyone if we sign off
something that reflects other reports
made made to counsel and has been
through the process so I'm happy thank
you and it was just one thing that I
wasn't very happy about but that's on
page 98 would know and it's the right oh
yeah 1314 stretch 2015 10 is really like
to answer that in person I think you're
honestly is more complete on that I
think I know what you've explained to me
yeah he should it just wants be highly
explained to us before but it was
released a few yeah you months ago yes
that's good idea yeah him and it was
people going bankrupt and yeah the old
here people don't yeah yeah yeah that
yeah I mean we have been I think we and
there's some mistaken we have been
through yes yeah this lowest on we
absolutely gelatin yeah yeah yeah yes
thank you
one of the things that you know we have
pretty advice over yet yeah meeting our
controller transpose here look I know if
at the last sense for us to take it from
oh yeah and all the bottom thing is
action we take a share of that rather
than whole thing because that's for the
preceptors the county takes Saudi cousin
of it on that now on the council tax and
on the business of a thumb and takes 50
person eat on that so things like that
so it's not the whole thing no one can
see me some depth lost gamut from page
12 it's just a pair of aged actually the
very top figure there millionaire taken
so yeah I take it that the barley noon
or is it no that's the whole assets the
the entire castle portfolio of the
council including the vehicles including
the properties Leon and the equipment
furniture and so on so forth the whole a
saturated state again and the dust cars
and the disclosed you have a detail to
some extent the leader breakdown between
the various categories on notes 12 which
is up above each page 26a 26 8.26
asbury celanese risk assessment the two
big items of the balance sheet on 8 12
is actually the property plant and
equipment and the pension figure which
is 20 7830 so they have satisfied
themselves who what amendments we had in
terms of value in those numbers for more
questions on this report what you want
to dance with Facebook page but there
are 66 pages very persuasive lat I think
the fact that it that's it for today is
good old state there is the last night
thanks yeah it's worth mentioning
140,000 very was mentioning about the
grant income on page 8 11 what what this
means is actually we should have shown
it as part of the 11 3889 figure sorry
having a pattern we showed it as part of
the 11 388 net figure which is on your
right hand further column the last
column net expenditure 11 3883 showed it
as part of that but correctly speaking
we should have shown it as part of the
taxation and nonspecific grant income
which is 11-7 973 figure so instead of
showing it on the top you should have
shown it at the bottom but it doesn't
change the total figure of 1569 either
way
right so exact like any more questions
okay cool thank you there are three ages
for it whatsoever sorry Jen can I ask
receipt or matter presumably this is now
this is down signed with the resolution
we we take here the Republic have
opportunity to question these accounts
like they cannot the end and then if
they put on the put on deposit and
display you for a period of time that's
right dear okay with you recommend
recommendation is for the financial
statements recruitment son by the
Chairman divinity from he's better
ensure that the movement in EMR
preserves be noted yes fine I'm sorry
I'm gonna polish you sleep inside
because